ROGER MARTINEZ: So
you decided that you
want to move your application
or some of your infrastructure
from an on-premises
VMware vSphere environment
to Google Cloud Compute Engine.
That's great.
There's only one thing standing
in your way, the migration
itself.
There are a lot of things
that you need to consider
when planning a migration.
How do you choose which
services you need?
How will you test your
application before moving it?
How can you minimize
any downtime
associated with migration?
Luckily, Google Cloud
offers a managed service
for migrating to Compute Engine.
Today, I'm going to help you
get familiar with the latest
release of Migrate
for Compute Engine.
Like the name suggests,
Migrate for Compute Engine
lets you migrate
your virtual machines
from your on-premises
data center
onto Google Cloud
Compute Engine.
It's a managed service.
So all of its functionality is
baked right into Google Cloud.
That means you can manage
your migration from start
to finish from the Cloud
Console or, if you want,
you can use a cloud API for
programmatically migrating
workloads.
It's got some
built-in testing that
will help you validate things
before you make the move.
And there is no
client-side software
that you need to
worry about installing
on your virtual machines.
All of that sounds great.
But moving your virtual machines
from your own on-prem racks
to Google Cloud is a big move.
Let's clarify what that
process looks with Migrate
for Compute Engine.
Before anything, you'll need
to create a host project.
This is the Google Cloud project
that will control the migration
process.
This can be the same
project that will eventually
host your migrated VMs.
But you do have the option
of using a separate target
project.
You also need to have the
Migrate Connector running
from your on-premises
vSphere environment.
Migrate Connector will set your
on-premise vSphere environment
as a migration source and
establish a secure data
path between it and
your host project.
This is accomplished
using Google Cloud
APIs over port 443.
And the traffic can be
routed via the internet, VPN,
private Google access, or
dedicated interconnect.
Once Migrate Connector is
set up in your environment,
it will be able to
perform storage operations
against your VM disks, create
your on-prem VM inventory,
and stop and monitor
your source VMs.
All of that is done
using the vSphere APIs.
To get Migrate
Connector going, there
are some prerequisites
steps you'll
need to complete, like
creating a vCenter user,
generating SSH keys, and
configuring network access.
I'll include a link to the
additional setup associated
with Migrate Connector in
this video's description.
Once you've got Migrate
Connector and your host
project all set up,
the migration process
can begin going
through its six phases.
Phase 1, onboarding--
this is when
you'll choose which VMs
you're going to migrate.
The list of virtual
machines that are available
will appear on
the console thanks
to the Migrate Connector.
Once you choose
your machines, you
move on to phase 2, replication.
During the replication
phase, the disk data
from the source VM will begin
its replication to Google Cloud
by creating VMware snapshots.
This is done without having
to take the VM offline.
So there's no downtime here.
After the initial
replication, Compute Engine
will then perform
incremental replications.
These are replications
of the disk that occur
at a regular time interval.
These incremental replications
can be paused and resumed
as you see fit.
As replication continues,
you move on to phase 3,
setting your target.
This is when you specify
your landing zone, where
you want your VM to migrate to.
The target details include
the project, instance type,
and network settings.
You don't have to create a
compute instance yourself
because Migrate
for Compute Engine
will take care of
doing that for you.
After setting your target,
onto phase 4, the test clone--
here's where you actually
clone your source VM
to a Compute Engine instance
for testing purposes
using the latest
replication data available.
During this phase, you
should perform all the tests
and validations
that you need for
your particular application.
The source VM continues
to run as well as
the incremental replications.
The test clone is
optional, but definitely
recommended to ensure a smooth
phase 5, the cut-over phase.
This is it.
During the cut-over phase,
the source VM is stopped,
replication is
finalized and ended,
and a new Compute
Engine instance
is created on Google Cloud,
the latest replication data.
This phase will cause a
short amount of downtime.
So a maintenance
window will need
to be implemented while you
turn down the origin machine
and redirect traffic
to the cloud.
If all goes well, you'll
be able to make it
to the sixth and final phase,
finalizing your migration.
At this phase, all replications
data and storage resources
associated with the migration
of your VMs are deleted
and the VM state is
set to finalized.
You've migrated your
VM to Compute Engine.
For more details on
those six phases,
check out the documentation for
VM migration lifecycle linked
in the description.
The goal of Migrate
for Compute Engine
is to give you a frictionless
migration experience.
This is largely
accomplished by performing
agentless replication
and by leveraging
vSphere and Google Cloud APIs.
By including the ability
to deploy test clones,
you're able to test
workloads before having
to make the big move.
Best of all, the end-to-end
migration journey
is centralized in
the Cloud Console.
There, in the
migration dashboard,
you'll be able to see all
the migrations in flight,
view migration events,
manage sources and targets,
and create VM groups so that
you can perform bulk migration
tasks on multiple VMs at once.
So what do you think about
Migrate for Compute Engine?
I hope that my walk-through
of the migration phase
has helped you determine how
Migrate for Compute Engine
can help you get your on-prem
applications into the cloud.
If you want to learn more about
Migrate for Compute Engine,
check out cloud.google.com
/migrate/computeengine,
and check out the link in
the description for a free
assessment to estimate
your cloud migration costs.
Thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]